million two games at facebook so let's
have yuando
welcome
if you know you're muted
try that hey hello everyone can you hear
me now
can you hear me now hello
yes well i can hear you okay sorry
let me try again
okay i think now it should work
can you see this wait can you see the
screen
yes we can see it okay cool nice so
uh my name is juan don tien so i'm a
research scientist also manager
in facebook research today i'm going to
talk about
our recent several works on learning
multi-agent collaborations with
decomposition
so first i want to introduce a little
bit of myself
so i'm going to i'm having like two
different directions one is
reinforcement learning
and the other is radical understanding
of deep models and in this case
so in this phase in this talk i'm going
to talk a little bit on reinforcement
inside because it's a reinforcement
examiner
and on a theoretical understanding of
deep learning paper we also actually
do some understanding of student teacher
models and also recently we actually
applied our approach to self-sufficient
learning and
understand why it works and breaking the
the black box but
this time i'm going to omit that and
focus on the first part
so i'm going to talk about three
different papers uh in this
30 minutes talk which is an ambitious
goal uh so
i'm going to be a little bit faster in
terms of like the pace
and and also leave a lot of details in
the paper and also in the detailed
slides so the first paper i'm going to
talk about is the multi-agent ad hoc
team player with
three attribution q functions so this
paper is already
being open source and all the code is
online and people can play with that
this is a joint collaboration with uc
berkeley and also
at ucsd and ocean high university so
mutated reinforcement has been like uh
making a strong a very great progress
in recent years i mean we have seen like
a lot of uh
uh results from open ai and demand they
actually solve
uh these problems with very heavy
computational resources
uh by computing uh by basically training
like a mid-loss agent
at the same time and uh ask this agent
to compete with against each other so
that the
the performance become better and better
and from a theoretical point of view
i basically like for multi-agent
collaboration we want to talk about uh
there are two different things we want
to think about one is how to
efficiently train collaborative agents
at the same time
right so the second question is uh i
mean we don't want this collaborative
agent to be
uh very dedicated and also very over
fitted to
the same this task right we want them to
be adapt to a new team configurations in
test time without fine tuning
so in order to do to achieve these two
goals we propose this collaborative q
learning
uh so this is basically like uh based on
the first principle and
we want to basically find using the
first principle to understand
how agent can collaborate and what kind
of
uh collaboration and also what kind of
uh
computation model we can derive from the
first principle all right so and
so we start with thinking about the
value function decoupling in
collaborative settings so if you think
about the drawing value function
uh we joined uh from s1 all the way to
sk
where this s is basically the state of
all this agent i so
if you want to just directly formulate
this joint value function you have these
three
different uh negative points so that
things are very hard to deal with
first of all it has exponential capacity
to estimate this function you need
exponential
samples to fill in this table which is
uh
which is not possible the second one is
that there's no decentralized
execution which is something we really
want what what do we mean by the central
execution is that each agent should be
able to execute uh by its
device song from its own local
observations
right so but uh since this v joins uh is
a function of all the asian states it's
hard to deal with
and the third one is it's not able to
generalize with new agent and team
members
so and what can we do uh for that right
so in this paper we basically talk a
little bit about
um think about like how can we mod agent
collaborations using reward attribution
so uh we think this we think about the
what is the motivation
for the agent to collaborate right so we
basically try to decompose this
motivation
into the term called assign rewards so
we think about
each agent has a decentralized value
function vi
and that vi is actually conditioned on
assign rewards eye
and this assign rewards uh is given by
some
centralized mechanism and once the sun
reward is there
and each agent is only acting uh
based on the its own state as well as
design with rewards
and given that the assignment was each
coupled from each other
so that's actually the idea and the
motivation of this work
so and then people might think okay
since this is true
but how can we do this assign rewards
right so this assignment was is actually
can be computed from this
following optimization functions so
considering that we are actually
maximizing
uh some kind of function that is the
join reward
and the joining word is basically like
the the summation of all this uh
local v functions and you take the
maximum of all these assigned rewards
so that you probably assign all these
rewards so that the value functions
is maximized okay so we obviously need
an
objective i need a constraint so that
these assign rewards won't exceed the
external words you can get
right which is the condition that i put
in the second part of this equation
but obviously this is still a hard
problem because
first of all you need to solve this
problem at every timestamp in the
joint execution which is a very hard
problem and second
it's still not decentralized because
when you're solving problems you need
all the state putting together so that
the problem can be solved
but interestingly we actually find
there's a theorem that
you can show in the in certain
conditions you actually can find a
reward assignment
and this rom assignment called the ah
hat i for each of this
agent so that it simplifies two
properties the first property is it only
depends on
the local uh observation of uh
the agent i so basically the local for a
given agent eyes point of view
it can see like a bunch of other agent
state and
we denote that as the si local and we
can show that there is this a local
assignment
a real assignment that it only depends
on this local uh
joint state but not the entire state and
the third and second
that reward assignment is uh
is actually if you pull up them together
it's actually a good reasonable good
solution
the solution that you put them together
which is the
r hat is actually has a lower bound
uh in term of uh in terms of its
performance
uh compared to optimal assignment so
based on that
so what we can think about is instead of
like solving this problem
i found this like a formulation in one
shot
and that requires all the state of all
the agents
what we can do is we can actually ask
each agent to take a look at its local
state
and then uh and its own state and also
its state
around it and then you put all them
together and try to learn a function
directly uh from this local state
combinations
all the way to its local uh to this
reward assignment and that before
assignment will be used
uh to uh guide agents uh
uh edges moves right so once we have
that then we can actually think about
okay so because this reward has this
kind of structure maybe you can do a
tailor expansion
for these q functions right so because
the q function is also a function of
this uh
local reward assignment so it can
actually be
using this compositional rule of data
expansion we actually can decompose
this q function into two different terms
the first term is called
q alone which basically only model
uh the q function component that is only
depending on the
local state of that particular of uh
particular
uh agent i so you only need to import
that particular
agent-i state there without knowing all
the rest of the state including the
state
that is around you and the second term
is also they actually called a
co-collaboration
in that collaboration term and it's
actually only depends on the
local observation of the agent state so
by localization what i mean is
it's not only including the local state
of the agent's
eye but also include its surrounding uh
state of the other agents that is that
the agent i can actually perceive
right so you can't just put them
together and also from this table
expansion you can actually see that
the second term needs to be zero uh if
uh yeah what use if the agent i is in a
long state in which like the agent i
does not really see other people's
uh state so then it actually becomes
uh one a kind of uh
regularization and this actually they
give you like a natural algorithm
right that algorithm they basically say
that we can just decompose the q
function into these two components and
that we actually
input put the regularization in the
second component
and so that you can trend these two
things in the same time
so that's actually very simple approach
uh you can get from the serial
derivation
so we actually apply that idea and try
this to starcraft 2 multi-agent
challenge which is a
empirical benchmark that in which
the agent our reinforcement agent need
to
control a multiple agent multiple small
units in this game so that to compete
against
the the other group of agents that is
controlled by the computer
by uh the the human design rules
and we actually find that our approach
called color q
and also color cube but with attention
actually does
much better in term of uh uh performance
the liberal wing rates
are given the number of uh same amount
of environment steps
used to train the model so uh basically
like of all these figures we basically
show that our approach that is shown
by uh purple and also brown i mean they
are actually doing a very good job in
terms of in
all these different environments and in
all these tasks are actually pretty hard
tasks
and these tasks are actually um regarded
as a very hard task and
if you try like a simple approaches this
won't work that way
and no matter for that and we actually
see that
the clock you actually perform very well
in a different uh
uh i think ad hoc team play so if we
actually add
or swap or removing units in a test time
and we actually just use this trend
model on this uh
test time environment we actually see
our approach is actually doing a
reasonably good job
compared to other approaches so that's
actually a while very interesting as
well because
because of this decomposition it somehow
learns
the the structure decomposition and
actually i can be adapted to other
situations quite well and finally we
also
tried basically using uh checking like a
different component of this color queue
and see whether uh e uh all these
components are necessary
right so we basically say okay how about
we get rid of this
loss function in which this q
decomposition
this q collab is not necessary to be
zero
when uh the agent is alone all right so
if we
could get rid of that we actually see
that the curve is actually doing much
worse
right so it's actually can be compared
become comparable with existing
approaches
but with this loss function our approach
is doing much better showing that this
decomposition makes sense and the
realization is also
doing a very good job okay so this is
the first
paper and forgive me for this fast pace
but
we have several papers to cover and let
me know if you have more questions
and more comments after the series of
talks
the second paper that i'm going to
mention is another paper they're trying
to
improve the collaboration of
multi-agents
using a joint policy search so this is
basically like a focus on more on these
game settings
in perfect information games in which
each of these players they don't need to
they don't necessarily like learn or see
each other's like
uh states so here's like a one electric
example
so suppose we have two players one is
alice and that is mob
and the alice has two private cars
either
has one private card and by that private
car can be either
uh speed a or uh or a hot air
right so an x can send a private public
signal to bob so that bob can guess
what the card is so because the private
signal has three different choices
so we actually see uh six symmetric
solutions
right so here's like a table that lists
like just one possible solutions but
there could be lots of other solutions
in that particular solution what you see
is the alice action
number two is actually not used because
there's a two uh
card but three signals right so uh
but uh if we change the game rule by a
little bit
saying how how about uh if you send
signal to
the signal we actually get an additional
small reward
so in addition to whether uh bob has gas
correctly from alice hint
so if the game rule has changed a little
bit then what happens is
that if you start with the existing
solution it's going to be super hard
for you to change the policy from
address point of view
or from opponent rule because from
from either person's point of view it's
actually very risky to change their own
policy
right so this channel their own policy
united if that
they change their own policy unitedly
then it runs risk that
the communication is not working at all
and
you won't get any reward so let's
actually bring about this problem right
so for
pure mutation collaborative games a
united
optimization of policy doesn't really
improve
overall values so and uh if you check
back like a lot of lots of like
empirical results
the empirical algorithms that people
have tried
and usually what people do is we fix
we basically treat the environment as a
constant and try to optimize the policy
from one agent point of view and this
actually will get into trouble
uh in this kind of settings right so
another example is like that so this is
like a more
uh example uh more examples from the
real world
is that i mean if you have two players
who are both
can speak english and speak french but
they may get trapped into local minima
by just talking about
french but none of them want to switch
to another
language so this actually corresponds to
this uh
this game tree in this incomplete
information game set in
imperfect information game setting so in
this game settings like each of these
players they basically don't know each
other's
uh uh hidden state and they basically
want to figure out
uh one joint policy so that uh this
joint policy is not local minimum
but unfortunately we're going to see a
local minimum here for us for example
here
if you just both of them choose french
french then there's a local national
equivalent which is 0.5 because one of
the players does not really speak french
well
but on the other side there's actually
another uh
group of optimal solutions which is
english english
right so in that case how can we deal
with that so one natural idea
to deal with that is can we actually uh
change the policy of two agents at the
same time
right so that i will be like a one
solution for that for example if you can
change these three policies of these two
places at the same time
then they can actually get to the same
solution that optimal solution obviously
but in order to do that uh you want to
basically like
write down the formulation about uh
uh about the policy changes right so
what you want to do is if you change the
policy of these two
uh information sets at the same time
what do we do value changes
right so but this actually is a hard
problem especially for incomplete
imperfect information game
this is because improv information game
uh the game tree is not
not as not a tree anymore it actually
can be a digraph
so that's the worst reason of that is
because uh i mean the information that
you see
from one player may not be uh available
from from the other player's point of
view because of that you're going to see
this uh this game trees are basically
uh span here and then go back to the
other states so this actually makes
things very complicated
so but fortunately we actually
discovered there's actually some
properties
in this uh uh in in this formulation
and we actually find interesting density
which is called the poisson density
this is a quantity which has two
properties the first property is that if
you sum all these
poisson densities together you actually
will get
the overall value changes right so here
like sigma is the current policy and
sigma prime is the new policy
and v sigma bar is basically the value
of this current policy and v
sigma prime is the value of the improved
policy
so if you compute the difference between
the two this is something that you want
you want to find the sigma bar so that
is v sigma bar
this v sigma prime is better than v
sigma
right so you have two properties first
is if you sum of them together you get
uh this difference in term of the values
and the second
is if you sum uh this if
you check this rule in a region uh where
the point doesn't change
then this rule is actually automatically
become zero
so no matter whether or not its upstream
or downstream states
has been has a change policy or not
right so this is actually quite
interesting
because of these two properties we
actually can arrive at this main theorem
the mainstream basically tell you
uh the overall value changes due to
police changes can be decomposed
uh into uh some of uh
of this val this participant density
rules
so and you can you only need to add all
the
rules in this active information set in
which the policy will change
and this inactive information set
actually doesn't matter so this actually
creates a
much interesting and uh
and also like more effective way of
computing these overall value changes
so based on that uh we actually can
develop our own approach called the
drawing policy search so the point
search is actually very simple you start
from a
starting uh policy uh which is starting
from the information set
i1 and then you change that it's on so
as policy and then once you check the
policy you
dig down into the consequence of
its chain of policy so by doing a debt
first search
so when the debt first search has
reached a given depth
you use the previous theorems to compute
the policy changes
because the policy changes can be
computed efficiently
whose capacity is proportional to the
number of
active information sets in which the
price has changed
and regardless of how many police how
many other information
sets that has somehow been changed and
this i mean this search can be done in a
more efficient amount
so once you have done that then you
actually can apply this
to any existing policy improvements
approaches
and compare that with other uh existing
approaches and we see that
in multiple small games uh that is
defined in a paper
in definition one two and three in for
the
we actually see like our approach as
doing much better in terms of the
drawing rewards
right so we actually see that this
approach can actually improve the
existing process by jumping out of the
local minima
that is trapped uh by running these
approaches and we actually see and also
apply this to
a bridge which is like a very uh
old game of 100 years and it's an improv
information with four players
and each players that the two of these
players are forming a team either
from another team they're competing with
each other so there's
both a collaborative and a competitive
component
on that and our goal is trying to
improve the collaborative component
between you and your teammate
right it has a very large state space so
that you cannot invent all possible
states
so if you run like a h2c still play on
top of that this
bridge building you actually see like
things actually convert to local minima
quite easily and after that it's hard to
get the trend better
but if we try our approach uh we
actually see that
our approach achieve a much better
performance and uh you can actually
evaluate
is a resulting model we against ww5
which is a champion
of computer bridge tournament in
multiple years and we see that
without the training with wfi we just
train by ourselves
and also without using any human
knowledge we actually
is able to beat w5 spinning phrase
in a double dummy evaluation by a large
amount
okay so that's the second paper
and finally i'm going to talk a little
bit about another paper that is actually
nothing to do with multi-agent but
it's actually a very cool paper and i'm
going to spend some time on
discussing that in this seminar because
it's actually
a touch and a very important problem
in reinforcement exploration so the the
basically the idea here is kind of very
simple it has very simple idea but
the performance is super good so we're
going to see
uh why we haven't figured out like why
that's the case but we want to
first introduce the paper and hopefully
we can trigger more kind of thoughts
about the interesting
theoretical explanation of it so here uh
we switch be a little bit and talk about
uh environment exploration but with past
reward
right so here's like one very simple uh
environment and when we have an agent
which has partial observability
and agent's goal is to reach to the goal
that is shown
in this purple uh cycles right so the
agenda in order to achieve the goal the
audience first needs to explore the
space
and needs to pick the key in the corner
and then use the key to open this locked
door
and enter that into this door to reach
the goal right but the problem with that
is that the
agent does not really see the goal and
also the agent does not really get the
reward
at any intermediate step right there's
no reward if you
went around there's no rewarding key
there's no reward when you
open a door there's only reward when you
reach the goal
so this actually makes it super
complicated and very hard so
in order to achieve uh uh some kind of
exploration properties one thing
people usually do is to basically add an
intrinsic reward in addition to the
external reward
for the agent right so the agent will
be attempt to visit states that has a
very infrequent visitation counts
right so that's something that people
usually do but then like people might
ask okay how about
in a state in a situation that we don't
really have a tabular
representation uh some in some
situations that you have exponential
number of state to explore
what should we do right so uh one thing
that we could do
is uh we basically can use uh we just
called it ind which is called
the random random network distillation
in which
we actually trained two networks so one
is the random fixed teacher network that
you don't touch
you don't train but there's another
network which is called still network
that can be learned from teacher so the
the first time you visit like one state
and uh you basically train your student
network so that's do network actually
learn uh to achieve a lower
uh prediction error so with a lower low
prediction error this basically means
that
the state has a higher validation counts
so you can approximate this end
this way but there's issues in these
inds
right so the id actually has issues if
you actually run this
foreign maze and what happens is for
your first explore
a few interesting regions but after a
while you actually move back and forth
into two already export regions because
the policy is already being trained
to only go to these two parts heavily
right so here's like one interesting uh
it's very cool
uh very simple experiments right running
these multi-core problems
so you have a state s0 and then you
start from this state
and there's four different colors you
can go right each corner have different
lengths
and what you actually see if you run
like an ind or counter-based kind of
exploration
is that they will get stuck into one of
two corridors and the narrative is the
other corridors
because of this kind of problems and you
actually compute entropy
of limiting different colors and you see
like this both of these entropies are
quite low
compared to uh our approach which is the
be bold approach that we will be
representing uh we were going to talk
about in next slides
so in the next slicer we're going to
have this is basically the idea of
people very simple
so we actually have inclusive rewards
but we instead of using this in inverse
of rotation counts
as these intrinsic rewards we actually
use the difference of
the variation counts along the trident
tree
so we also do a regularization by
cutting off the negative increasing
rewards along the way
by using um using a value functions you
also multiply
all these things by an episodic mutation
counts which is computed uh
in as a hash function uh in each of this
environment
this is basically used to prevent uh an
agent to visit
like a state multiple times to get like
multiple
intrinsic rewards so we basically the
idea here is actually
the the the thoughts is uh the
uh the the uh yeah the intuition is
actually here right so you start from
the start
from a small room and if once you do the
exploration you actually will find that
there will be some of the bottleneck
whose invitation account is super super
low but once you put the high rewards of
these bottlenecks
so what happens is the validation counts
of all the sports index will become
higher
and this actually will reduce the
increasing rewards and
enable the agent to go go beyond that
bottleneck and move to the next
move to the next room that's the idea
but there's no theory
on top of that and we are still
exploring why that's the case why this
can actually give
performance so here i'm uh i'm talking a
little bit on this performance here
so we actually evaluate this approach in
very simple approach in like a mini grid
environment which is a procedure
generated environment
that it that is used to evaluate
exploration
in uh for different algorithms so we see
that uh
our approach actually solves like uh 12
most
challenging tasks in these environments
while the the prior the prior arts has
been
uh trying and hard and only saw half of
them
and also if you check this uh curves in
terms of the validation count
in terms of this environment steps
versus the average return
and we see that in the hard tasks our
approach which is shown in the purple
in light purple actually has a much
better performance compared to other
approaches
we don't really see a promising results
on the other approaches but our approach
were able to address
these hard problems and we checked this
pure exploration results and we see that
people
actually did much better in terms of the
environmental steps
and in in comparison ind only basically
do
get stuck into the fifth room after
double number of
environment steps and we also try this
uh same idea in the net hack which is a
new environment where we
one of our queries have proposed this is
a very famous game in 1980s and people
have tried their best to play this game
and this is basically and we actually
did a very good job in six hours in
nethack
so uh future work uh based in this
approach is
first this is a very simple approach in
the super performance
so people another question would ask
it's like what is the understanding of
it
why this very simple approaches actually
achieve good performance
right so this actually after some kind
of thinking uh one idea
that we are thinking about is maybe this
are related to exploration infection and
vp
right so because the environment in the
real world is kind of factor there's a
lot of
components there so in that case like
what will be the key assumption we need
to make
in effect mdp so that this kind of
exploration would work but this is still
ongoing work
and this is basically the presentation
and i thanks for your attention and
i welcome any questions
okay thank you so that's a very
impressive set of results
so there are many questions for undo and
for shai and again so we'll
we're going to defer them after the last
talk
all right so please stay until uh
end of the break okay thanks okay thank
you
okay uh